[Music]
last night here in LA there was a
different kind of nervous energy I was
there as spider-man homecoming star Tom
Hollands shut down Hollywood Boulevard
at his huge premiere I'm losing my mind
right now
[Music]
we're very proud of Tom's I never
thought I'd wind up being like a father
figure to another Avengers but I
couldn't pick a better character or
actor to do it with spider-man
aka a 21 year old Brit Tom Holland is
our new summer crush thanks in part to
this shirtless shot Tom brought his
family along for his big night and
Instagram their day we look to the main
event they have the command I have a big
old sport head and the frizz is real
tonight I got my mom my brother Harry my
brother Patti Betty but did he make you
work out with him today
show me the gun oh please tell me this
how proud are you of your big brother uh
very proud yeah I try to be like him
spider-man Home Coming picks up where
Captain America Civil War left off with
Peter Parker back in high school
co-star zendaya plays a classmate in
real life these two are such good
friends they can even share work for the
same size but no one has this like
really nice leather jacket and he was
like running out of clothes on the press
tour take it take it so he still adds it
somewhere oh how good does the day look
he always does yeah he looks like cotton
candy and that pink Ralph and Russo
dress and she has this guy to thank for
it law wrote the stylist who's also
behind all of Sterling's amazing Kate
has a great time
[Music]
you